und wie gehen wir rein in den plenarsaal
der petra bauer die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin hat bereits
den nächsten tagesordnungspunkt
aufgerufen
es ist ein historischer anlass vor 30
jahren nämlich im märz 1992 hatte der
bundestag beschlossen und das zwar
einstimmig damals eine enquetekommission
zur aufarbeitung und folgen der
sed-diktatur in deutschland einzusetzen
es gibt dazu heute deswegen eine
vereinbarte debatte es gab damals von
dieser enquete kommission über 80
sitzungen ein teil davon auch öffentlich
in bonn berlin rostock alle auch in
dresden und erfurt
es kamen sachverständige und zeugen aus
ganz deutschland zu wort nach zwei
jahren kurz vor der bundestagswahl 1994
gab es die ergebnisse und man hat aber
gleichzeitig festgestellt dass das thema
noch lange nicht aufgearbeitet ist und
deswegen gab es 1995 eine zweite
enquete-kommission
die dann arbeitete bis 1998
und sie werden sicher noch mal einiges
hören was damals
diskutiert wurde was damals in dieser
enquete kommission deren vorsitzender
übrigens der cdu abgeordnete rainer
eppelmann war
ehemaliger bürgerrechtler und heute
übrigens noch vorsitzender der
bundesstiftung zur aufarbeitung der ddr
diktatur
so ich bitte darum dass sowohl die
grünen als auch die fdp als auch die
linke jetzt endlich platz nimmt bitte
ich
wiederhole mich wir kommen zum
tagesordnungspunkt viele dann dort auch
in der lobby erinnern wie richtung
abzugeben
auf der ehrentribüne haben mitglieder
stellvertretende mitglieder sowie
sachverständige der beiden in der
zwölften und dreizehnten wahlperiode
eingesetzten am cat kommissionen zur
aufarbeitung der sed-diktatur
und zu deren folgen und nachwirkungen
für die deutsche einheit platz genommen
ich begrüße sie ebenso wie die sed
opferbeauftragte evelyn zupke sehr
herzlich im namen des gesamten hauses
wir freuen uns dass sie diese debatte
beiwohnen
ich eröffne die aussprache das wort hat
die staatsministerin claudia roth
liebe frau präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr verehrte gäste
man könnte sich keine bessere werbung
für ein geschichtsstudium vorstellen als
die geschichts kletternden aufsätze des
russischen präsidenten
das habe ich vor kurzem in einem artikel
gelesen wir alle lernen gerade dass wir
besser mehr gelernt hätten wir wissen zu
wenig über die geschichte der ukraine
wir wissen vor allem zu wenig über
unsere eigene die deutsche verstrickung
in die jüngere geschichte dieses landes
denn wissen wir mehr
könnten wir besser verstehen in welcher
verantwortung wir stehen
und wir erleben wir erleben den
unterschied zwischen
demokratischen und autokratischen
staaten im umgang mit ihrer eigenen
geschichte hier jetzt im deutschen
bundestag und weniger als zwei
flugstunden weiter östlich in moskau
zwei enquete kommissionen hier und in
ihrer folge eine bundesstiftung die sich
seit mehr als 20 jahren um den
aufklärerischen umgang mit einem
schmerzhaften kapitel deutscher
geschichte bemüht ein auto grad dort der
krieg führt um seine fiktion russischer
geschichte und größe mit waffengewalt
durchzusetzen
wer also fragt ob man das thema sed
unrecht nach 30 jahren nicht zu den
akten legen könnte ob nicht gerade diese
geschichte zwischen ost und
westdeutschen stehe und eine dauernde
beschäftigung damit nur andere das alte
wunden heilten dem will ich sagen
sich der eigenen geschichte stellen das
verlangt gerade diesen aufmerksamen und
diesen genauen blick setzt voraus dass
wir auch eigene schuld und eigenem
versagen nicht ausweichen die
bundesrepublik musste diesen blick auf
die ns geschichte mühsam und gegen
jahrzehntelange innere widerstände
lernen aber sie ist an dieser
auseinandersetzung
gewachsen gewachsen auch in den
vergangenen 30 jahren aus der
auseinandersetzung
mit der ddr-vergangenheit ja sie ist
auch an den auseinandersetzungen darüber
gewachsen ob wir von einer deutschen und
demokratischen republik einer sed
diktatur oder einem unrechtsstaat
sprechen wollen oder sprechen müssen wie
sollten wir an solchen debatten nicht
wachsen wir würden es nur dann nicht
mehr wenn in unserem land die
auseinandersetzung mit der eigenen
geschichte staatlich reglementiert würde
wenn zivilgesellschaftliche
institutionen sowie memorial in russland
drangsaliert und liquidiert werden und
ein betoniertes geschichtsbild jeden
diskurs darüber
unterbinden würde das gegenteil ist der
fall und dazu haben auch und maßgeblich
beide enquete kommissionen und seit 1998
die bundesstiftung aufarbeitung
beigetragen
wir sind ein offenes land eine
vielfältigere eine buntere gesellschaft
geworden wir haben keine scheu uns auch
den unbequemen und bedrückenden orten
der ddr geschichte zu stellen in
hohenschönhausen an der früheren
berliner mauer in bautzen oder in
hoheneck ja und auch das gehört zur
wahrheit je offener die pluraler jede
demokratische diese gesellschaft wird
desto lauter und elemente wird der
widerstand wir können ihn auch immer
wieder hier im haus vernehmen deshalb
spreche ich von erinnern für die zukunft
aufarbeitung ist eine aufgabe für
generationen
sie ist nicht abgeschlossen sie wird es
auch niemals sein
sie kann es nicht sein denn jede
generation stellt ihre fragen an die
geschichte denn das vergangene fragt
immer in gegenwart und zukunft hinein ob
wir das wollen oder nicht wie wir gerade
erleben können stellt auch die
geschichte ihre fragen an jede
nachfolgende generation neu
und ich gebe zu auch ich sehe und
bemerke dass es kapitel unserer
geschichte gibt die ich mir erarbeitet
und die ich bearbeiten muss wie kapitel
der deutsch-deutschen geschichte der
gemeinsamen
ukrainisch deutschen aber auch der
russisch deutschen geschichte
in unserer aufmerksamkeit nicht
nachzulassen eben das bedeutet
historisches wissen für die zukunft
produktiv zu machen nichts anderes haben
die beiden enquete kommissionen
geleistet die stiftung zur aufarbeitung
der sed diktatur hat sich selbst
erinnerung als auftrag gestellt sie
begreift diesen auftrag als einen
dauerhaften prozess von erkenntnis und
vermittlung dazu gehört ganz zentral
auch das gedenken und die erinnerung an
die opfer staatlicher repression in der
ddr wie wir
wie wir unsere geschichte begegnen was
wir über sie wissen und wie wir mit ihr
umgehen bestimmt nicht nur unsere
gegenwart es wird unsere zukunft
bestimmen eine wissenschaftlich
fundierte aufarbeitung der sed diktatur
wie die beiden kommissionen sie
angestoßen haben wird antworten auf
fragen geben können die mit blick auf
unser künftiges verhältnis zu
autokratischen staaten wie russland
aktueller sind als uns lieb sein kann
ich danke ihnen
die kultur staatsministerin claudia roth
hat hier diese vereinbarte debatte
eröffnet so 30 jahren kehrt kommission
zur aufarbeitung der sed-diktatur
und sie hat gesagt aufarbeitung ist
niemals abgeschlossen auch heute gibt es
noch fördergelder der bundesstiftung zur
aufarbeitung der sed-diktatur für
projekte zur historischen einordnung der
sed-diktatur dieses jahr beispielsweise
immerhin 23 millionen euro sepp müller
für die union sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe mitglieder der
enquete-kommission über opfer auf der
tribüne und an den bildschirm als die
erste un kommission zur aufarbeitung der
sed-diktatur am 12 märz 1992 ihre arbeit
aufnahmen war ich gerade mal drei jahre
alt
ich bin zwar noch zu und in ddr zeiten
geboren habe aber selbst keinerlei
erinnerung an sie wie so viele aus
meiner generation
meine generation ist die erste
generation des wiedervereinten
deutschlands und wenn man die ergebnisse
der zwei enquetekommission zur
aufarbeitung der sed-diktatur liest dann
überwiegt zuallererst
ich bin der generation meiner eltern und
großeltern so unfassbar dankbar dass sie
für demokratie freiheit und
rechtsstaatlichkeit auf die straße
gegangen sind
dass sie mit all ihren mut wieso
unrechtsstaat zu fall gebracht haben dem
sage ich danke der siegeszug von
demokratie und marktwirtschaft schien
lange zeit unaufhaltsam der frieden in
europa wurde für viele von uns zur
gewohnheit beides prägte den zeitgeist
meiner generation
doch die zeiten haben sich geändert wir
sind durch putins menschenverachtenden
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine jetzt in
der bitteren realität angekommen es ist
allerhöchste zeit unsere sinne zu
schärfen
es ist allerhöchste zeit uns zu
vergewissern woher wir kommen und wohin
wir mit diesem land wollen die
ergebnisse der enquete kommissionen und
ich freue mich auch dass der ehemalige
bundestagspräsident wolfgang thierse
platz genommen hat zur aufarbeitung der
sed diktatur sind hierfür von
unschätzbaren wert vielen dank eine
historische dokumentation und ein
auftrag an die nachkommende generation
ja in meiner generation
jedweder verklärung oder verharmlosung
der sed-diktatur mit ganzer kraft
entgegen zu treten
hier im deutschen bundestag aber vor
allem auch im alltag von uns allen und
deswegen lassen sie mich eines der
nachfolgepartei der sed mit auf den weg
gehen liebe linke hören sie endlich auf
damit das sed regime zu verklären und
den menschen in ostdeutschland
einzureden dass die bundesrepublik
deutschland sie nicht wertgeschätzt
das ist grober unfug und das wissen sie
auch erkennen sie endlich an das
sed-regime die ddr wirtschaftlich gegen
die wand gefahren hat es kann nur eine
antwort auf diese erfahrung geben nie
wieder sozialismus
und zu meiner und zu meiner rechten in
diesem haus nur folgendes mehr an
stammtischen und doch telegramm kanälen
die bundesrepublik deutschland als
corona diktatur bezeichnet dafür
herrlich damit nicht nur die sed und ns
diktatur sondern der sägt am fundament
unserer demokratie
die uns allen heute ein leben in
freiheit und rechtsstaatlichkeit
ermöglicht das ist völlig inakzeptabel
und durch nichts zu rechtfertigen
er hatte frau staatsministerin roth
vielen dank für ihre worte
ich sitze auch gleich in einer ost runde
zusammen mit den opfern des sed-regimes
und ich möchte die gelegenheit nutzen
auch eine bitte deine opfer verbände an
sie heute vorzutragen sie wurden
mehrfach angeschrieben sicherlich wegen
corona technisch konnten sie sich noch
nicht treffen mit den opfern
staatsminister schneider ist dem schon
nachgekommen ich wollte die bitte heute
noch in diesem hohen hause loswerden
dass sie diesem wunsch der opfer des
sed-regimes nachkommen sich mit diesen
schnellstmöglich zusammensetzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine
generation ist die erste generation des
wiedervereinten deutschlands ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass wir die
generation sind die brückenbauer sein
wird ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
wir die generation sind die
verantwortung ihnen gegenüber zeigen und
in spalten in diesem land einen stopp
schützenden weil sie sich an dem tag auf
gemacht haben auf dem weg zu frieden für
freiheit und für demokratie und da sage
ich haben meiner generation danke ihnen
für ihre arbeit und ihren einsatz
herzlichen dank
captain bürger war das der fdp
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
fraktion
nächste rednerin wird jetzt sein kathrin
wurde für die sozialdemokratischen weil
ich da ist nicht versorgen der ausschuss
die anderen anwesenden
mitglieder
[Applaus]
und begrüßt das wort hat die kollegin
katrin wurde für die s bahn kann hat sie
schon gesehen und angesprochen worden
der ehemalige bundestagspräsident auch
auf der tribüne katrin budde jetzt für
die spd
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
im märz 1992 da war die transformation
der strukturbruch in der industrie die
veränderungen in jeder alltagssituation
im leben der menschen in der damals noch
in den damals noch jungen neuen
bundesländern in vollem gange nach circa
anderthalb jahren hat er sich einfach
alles verändert in jedem bundesland gab
es ein neues schulsystem die länder
waren gegründet unterschiedliche
zuständigkeiten in bund ländern
regierungsbezirken die es noch gab
landkreisen städten gemeinden das wurde
alles noch genug und betriebe in denen
ganze generationen gearbeitet hatten 40
jahre lang hatten sie arbeit und alltag
urlaub und zugehörigkeit geprägt waren
verschwunden sie wurden geschlossen oder
erst verkauft und dann geschlossen
binnen kurzer zeit war eine million
menschen arbeitslos geworden aber die
zahl der beschäftigten war noch
dramatischer versuchen 9,8 millionen
darin ist im herbst 89 67 in der 91 3,2
millionen menschen waren aus dem
arbeitsleben verschwunden ein drittel
der beschäftigten ostdeutschland und das
war erst der anfang die freude und demut
der friedlichen revolution
die freude über die deutsche
wiedervereinigung das wurde in vielen
familien überdeckt von ungewissheit
ungewissheit von zukunftsangst und nicht
nur die politischen opfer der
kommunistischen diktatur die verlangten
nach rehabilitation nach
wiedergutmachung nach anerkennung in
allen familien wurden fragen gestellt
meine mutter hat das mal so beschrieben
entlassenen freigestellten
ersatzmaßnahmen in arbeitsmarktmaßnahmen
das wurde von unten nach oben
stellvertretende direktorin wurden
abteilungsleiter abteilungsleiter wurden
gruppenleiter gruppenleiter wurden
mitarbeiter und die jeweils ehemaligen
mitarbeiterinnen mussten gehen so hielt
man sich länger im job das system der
ddr funktionierte der gruppenleiter
abteilungsleiter stellvertretende
direktorin waren mindestens sed oder
blog parteimitglied ich war 27 jahre alt
und die jüngste abgeordnete im landtag
von sachsen anhalt meine eltern an 56
jahre alt so alt wie ich heute bin und
dem vorruhestand
auch das mit eine folge der sed diktatur
der geteilten welt der geteilten
politischen militärischen und
ökonomischen systeme und in diese zeit
hinein wurde die erste
enquete-kommission des deutschen
bundestages zur aufarbeitung der folgen
der sed diktatur geboren 27 männer und
frauen mitglieder des deutschen
bundestages aller fraktionen
wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerinnen ein
theologe und schriftsteller ein jurist
und publizist sie stellten sich einer
riesengroßen aufgabe dafür herzlichen
dank
anfang der 90er jahre machte sich aus
vielen gründen und zufriedenheit breit
es wurde in der öffentlichkeit über
tribunale diskutiert die über die
russischen verfahren hinaus moralische
urteile fällen politische schuld
diskutieren und zu weisen sollten es
wurde über eine wahrheitskommission das
südamerikanischen vorbild nachgedacht
afrikanisch amerikanische vorbild
nachgedacht wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere war es markus meckel und er war
damals mitglied des bundestages und der
hat erzählt dass er nach gesprächen mit
martin gutzeit und einigen erfahrenen
parlamentarierin den vorschlag in die
öffentlichkeit gebracht hat eine enquete
kommission zu bilden dass dieser
vorschlag eines damals der oppositions
abgeordneten im bundestag aufgenommen
und realisiert wurde spricht für die
demokratische diskussionskultur unseres
das spricht auch dafür dass in unserer
parlamentarischen demokratie eben doch
auch mehrheiten jenseits der
parteipolitischen mehrheiten möglich
sind und ich will allen auf den
damaligen regierungsfraktionen danken
dass dies möglich waren denn es war gut
dass der bundestag es gewähltes und als
legitimiertes gremium sich dieser
aufgabe gestellt hat die kommission sah
es als ihre wichtige aufgabe an die
öffentliche kenntnis über die ddr zu
erweitern beurteilungen zu
differenzieren unterschiedliche
lebenserfahrungen zur sprache kommen zu
lassen sie fragte nach der
funktionsweise des systems der
repression nach verantwortlichkeiten
nach der situation der opfer und ihrer
perspektive nach dem alltagsleben unter
den bedingungen einer diktatur und immer
wieder wurde auch die gesamtdeutsche
perspektive in den blick genommen die
aufarbeitung der ddr geschichte war
damals und ist auch heute noch eine
gesamtdeutsche aufgabe
dass sie als eine solche gesehen wird
wurde damals erst nach und nach
wahrgenommen und ehrlich an uns alle die
frage gestellt wir müssen auch heute
noch darum kämpfen dass es so ist lassen
sie mich deshalb aus dem bericht der
enquete zitieren dabei war sich die amt
kommission stets bewusst dass die
historisch politische aufarbeitung der
sed diktatur auf eine ungleiche
betroffenheit der west- und ostdeutschen
bevölkerung der menschen in den alten
und neuen bundesländern trifft während
an die westdeutschen die von der sed
diktatur zumeist nicht existenziell
berührt waren kaum kritische fragen
gestellt werden sehen sich viele
ostdeutsche in einer situation der
selbstrechtfertigung die enquete
kommission macht auf die gefahr
aufmerksam dass die verständnislose
unsensible vergangenheitsbewältigung
gegenseitige vorurteile unter den
deutschen in ost und west wieder
aufleben und neu entstehen lassen könnte
bis heute wirkt das nach gefühlte
demütigen abwertungen verluste kämpfe um
neuanfang wir reden heute von der nicht
anerkennung der lebensleistung oder eben
doch
und es wirkt auch nach den
wahlergebnissen und in resignation
verstehen sie mich bitte wirklich nicht
falsch die deutsche wiedervereinigung
infolge der friedlichen revolution
möglich gemacht von ostdeutschen mutigen
bürgerinnen und bürger und akzeptiert
von den damaligen alliierten ist ein
riesengroßer glücksfall das leben in
einer demokratie das lernen arbeiten zu
entwickeln können chancen haben das ist
wunderbar aber die überwiegende last der
wiedervereinigung das haben die
ostdeutschen getragen und darauf und
dass dies anerkannt gehört hat schon die
erste enquete in gewesen ein weiteres
zitat wenn anderenorts hervorgehoben
wurde dass die aufarbeitung der ddr
vergangenheit hauptsächlich die menschen
im ehemaligen sozialistischen staat
deutscher nation berührt so heißt dies
keineswegs dass die bürger in der alten
bundesrepublik kaum oder gar nicht davon
betroffen werden das gegenteil ist
richtig sie sollen sagen so hat jürgen
fuchs in der letzten anhörung der
enquete-kommission zugespitzt und
ungerecht polemisch wie er selber
einräumte gefragt warum sie existiert
haben warum sie sich mit der teilung und
der verletzung der menschenrechte ab
fanden lassen sie mich etwas deutlicher
werden wir haben uns wirklich über die
westpakete zu weihnachten freut ein
paket kaffee zwei tafeln schokolade
löslicher zitronentee lux sei für
dominosteine in der regel im wert von 30
dem markt in diesem werk konnte man von
der steuer absetzen die politische ebene
hat sie an die wiedervereinigung
geglaubt ich glaube sie war genauso
überrascht wie wir davon dass die
revolution friedlich waren mir ist heute
klar als damals das ein politisches
eingreifen nicht möglich waren bis heute
klarer als damals dass ein eingreifen
krieg bedeutet hätte krieg zwischen der
nato und der militärischen und
militärischen ostblock das wollte keiner
und fallen ihnen wie mir die parallelen
auf mir gehen sie seit dem angriff
putins auf die ukraine nicht mehr aus
dem kopf wieder und diesmal wie aus
deutschen mit stehen wir da sehen
verzweifelt wie menschen sehen
verzweifelt zu vier menschen ermordet
werden eine demokratie überrannt wird
menschlich vielen familien
auseinandergerissen werden weil ein
militärisches eingreifen unsererseits
noch mehr krieg bedeuten würde ich
verstehe das intellektuell aber ich kann
das emotional nicht akzeptieren das
gleiche gilt übrigens für hongkong
vertreibern für belarus was kommt noch
georgien moldau und wenn hoffentlich
doch die demokratin siegen dort dann
werden sie mit zeitlichem abstand uns
das gleiche fragen was die an hätte die
alte bundesrepublik gefragt hat ich
werde keine zufriedenen anstellt
antworten haben im ergebnis der enquete
wurden dem deutschen bundestag
empfehlung vorgelegt
einige davon daueraufgabe die reha
gesetze für die opfer der
kommunistischen diktatur weil es immer
wieder neue erkenntnisse gibt die
weiterentwicklung des gedenkstätten
konzeptes aber gut funktioniert hat die
gründung der aufarbeitung der stiftung
aufarbeitung das ist ein ergebnis der
enquete-kommission schnell umgesetzt gut
gearbeitet vielen dank sie haben
großartiges in der zeit geleistet die
forschung zu diktatoren transformation
steckt noch in den kinderschuhen
das werden wir in dieser legislatur
angreifen da müssen wir uns darum
kümmern und die fragen die die
enquete-kommission aufgeworfen hat die
sind damals wie heute aktuell bei
geschichte ist nie abgeschlossen
sagte die vorsitzende des ausschusses
für kultur und
medien
[Musik]
für mich der fall dann schließlich den
möglichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte abgeordnete sehr
geehrte mitglieder der enquete
kommissionen es ist niemals ein dokument
der kultur ohne zugleich ein solches der
barbarei zu sein dieser satz von walter
benjamin kam mir in den sinn in der
vorbereitung auf die heutige debatte zur
aufarbeitung der sed-diktatur die
barbaren beginn verbrechen seien es die
nationalsozialisten oder später die
roten sozialisten und die darauf
folgenden generationen gründen und
kommissionen stiftungen baumann mehler
veranstalter eine höchst populäre
erinnerungskultur rund um das geschehene
verbrechen und unheil notwendig aber
bedrückend eines der zentralen
ergebnisse der ersten cd und kommission
in den 90er jahren lautete ich zitiere
der sed staat war eine diktatur er war
dies nicht durch fehlentwicklung oder
individuellen machtmissbrauch der kam im
einzelnen dazu sondern von seinen
historischen und ideologischen
grundlagen her zitat ende eine enorm
wichtige feststellung bei der wir eines
nicht vergessen dürfen die partei namens
die linke die seit 1990 im bundestag
sitzt die früher pds hieß die hieß zuvor
sed diese linke ist rechts identisch mit
der sed sie zählt noch heute von dem
vermögen das sie den bürgern der ddr
geraubt hat und sie fußt auch noch auf
denselben ideologischen grundlagen das
ist eine schande für dieses hohe haus
und für das land meine damen und herren
die ddr hieß ausbuchstabiert deutsche
demokratische republik daran sollten sie
bitte immer denken vor allem sie von der
cdu wenn sie sich hier gemeinsam mit
allen anderen bis hin zur linken die
demokratischen fraktionen nennen
demokratisch zu sein heißt nicht die
einzig vermeintlich richtige meinung und
eine hyper moralische gesinnung zu haben
demokratisch zu sein heißt den
wettbewerb der politischen ideen zu
akzeptieren echte alternativen
zuzulassen
sonst sind wir bei den blockparteien der
ddr die eine vielfalt vorgaukelten wo es
doch nur immer dasselbe in rot gelb oder
schwarz gab die ironie der geschichte
will es das alte missstände sich alle
erinnerung und mahnung zum trotz
hinterrücks wieder einschleichen
manchmal sogar dreist im gewand der
erinnerung und mahnung daherkommen der
abschlussbericht der zweiten enquete
hielt folgendes sehr wichtiges fest
zitat der anti totalitäre konsens als
teil einer demokratischen
erinnerungskultur ist eine der besten
bürgschaften dafür dass sich nicht
wiederholt was sich nicht wiederholen
darf zitat ende und diesen an die
totalitären kontext haben verlassen die
ehemalige familienministerin
schwesig spd und der ehemalige
innenminister
de maizière cdu die die
extremismusklausel abschafften so dass
linksradikale vereine wieder gefördert
werden konnten heftig bejubelt von
anetta kahane einer ehemaligen stasi
spitzel die heute wieder im
staatsauftrag auftrag zensur betreibt
man kann es sich nicht ausdenken diesen
anti totalitären konsens hat verlassen
die neuen innenministerin feser die in
einer antifa postille schreibt und auf
dem linken extremismus auge völlig blind
ist und dem dem banner des
antifaschismus jetzt wohl endgültig
staatsdoktrin geworden wird die freie
meinung heute wieder beschnitten und
sanktioniert andersdenkende gecancelt
und bestraft
antifaschistischer schutzwall
hieß die mauer bekanntlich im ddr
schauen zu ihrem eigenen schutz wohl
sind etliche ddr insassen die den weg in
die freiheit sucht an der mauer
verblutet ich liebe doch alle menschen
berühmten worte von stasi chef mielke
bereits vor sieben jahren schrieb der
stern in rhetorischer übertreibung
deutschland ist komplett ddr visiert
anpassung wird belohnt widerspruch übt
man besser still warum ist dergleichen
heute in den starts alimentierten medien
nicht mehr zu lesen weil sich alles
derart gebessert hat oder weil das
meinungsklima inzwischen noch
repressiver geworden ist bitte denken
sie darüber nach und bietet frau roth
schauen wir auf russland ja aber kehren
wir doch auch vor der eigenen tür vielen
dank
hinter teutenberg hat das wort für die
fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
der sed staat war eine diktatur
er war dies nicht durch
fehlentwicklungen oder individuellen
machtmissbrauch der kam im einzelnen
hinzu sondern von seinen historischen
und ideologischen grundlagen er die
hauptverantwortung für das unrecht das
von diesem system ausging trägt die ssid
die politische moralische verurteilung
der sed diktatur bedeutet keine
verurteilung der unterworfenen menschen
im gegenteil die deutschen in der
sowjetischen besatzungszone und der ddr
haben den schwereren teil der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte zu tragen gehabt
und schließlich zu den geistigen
grundlagen einer innerlich gefestigten
demokratie gehört ein von der
gesellschaft getragen anti totalitärer
konsens ich zitiere gern diese worte aus
dem entschließungsantrag mit dem sich
auf einem sehr breiten konsens der
deutsche bundestag 1994 zum
abschlussbericht der ersten enquete
kommission geäußert hat diese klarheit
in den feststellungen sie beruht wohl
auch noch auf der zeitlichen nähe darauf
dass die vergangenheit noch qualmte dass
die das unmittelbar erlebte noch sehr
nah war aus dem der einrichtung der
enquete kommission sprach auch das
ehrliche bemühen ist diesmal besser zu
machen und schneller mit der
aufarbeitung einer diktatur zu beginn
nicht erst auf eine nachfolgende
generation zu warten und ich sage das
ist richtig so die klarheit dieses
entschließungsantrages zeigt es
in meinem heimatland brandenburg wo es
aus gründen eine solche
enquete-kommission auch 2010 gab da war
ist meiner generation und anderen noch
mal
notwendig genau das für unser bundesland
aufzuarbeiten und manche moralische
indifferenz nicht mehr klar zu benennen
was eine diktatur war wer die
verantwortung trug diese entwicklung war
da schon klar zu spüren sehr geehrte
damen und herren es gibt natürlich nicht
nur schwarz und weiß auf der welt und
moralischer rigorismus ist fehl am platz
aber es ist eben auch nicht alles grau
in grau und politische und moralische
schuld für die unser strafrecht aus
gutem grund grenzen hat im rechtsstaat
die muss gesellschaftlich aufgearbeitet
werden im öffentlichen bewusstsein ist
dabei oft wenig präsent dass die
wiederaneignung der eigenen geschichte
ein zentrales anliegen der
bürgerrechtsbewegung in der ddr und auch
bei unseren nachbarn in ostmitteleuropa
war die gründung von der moral übrigens
fällt nicht ohne grund in diese zeit das
sputnik verbot etwa 1988 in der ddr
beruht auch auf einer intensiven
geschichtsdebatte in der sowjetunion die
man in der ddr beobachtete meine akte
gehört mir war das individuelle anliegen
der bürgerinnen und bürger der ddr die
hoheit über die eigene biografie zu
bekommen und gesellschaftlich ging es
darum die deutungshoheit über die
geschichte der diktatur den machthabern
zu entziehen die ein taktisches
verhältnis zur geschichte hatten sehr
geehrte damen und herren
wenn man nun
den beitrag dieser enquete kommission
für die politische kultur unseres landes
sich anschaut dann habe ich jetzt nicht
die zeit auf die vielfältigen beiträge
einzugehen dazu gehört allerdings
einerseits die auseinandersetzung als
gesamtstaatliche und
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe mit
dieser zweiten deutschen diktatur
dazu gehört dass die enquete-kommission
viel material einen wertvollen
steinbruch für forschung und politische
bildung hinterlassen hat dazu gehört
dass sie das leid der opfer und die
leistungen von widerstand und opposition
erstmals in den blickpunkt der
öffentlichkeit gerichtet hat und das war
bitter nötig denn die opposition sie
hatte kein staatstheater in der diktatur
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
wohl wichtigste ergebnis allerdings
finde ich ist die formulierung des anti
totalitären konsenses auch ganz aktuell
für unsere heutige auseinandersetzung
mit extremismus jürgen habermas
formulierte ihn 1994 bei einer anhörung
er zieht sagte zb diese aufeinanderfolge
von zwei diktaturen kann einer
lehrreichen optischen verstärkung der
totalitären gemeinsamkeiten dienen
dieses bekenntnis von habermas führte
dazu dass ein teil der öffentlichkeit
seinen kalten krieg gegen die
totalitarismustheorie hannah arendts
einstellte und diese theorie wieder
dorthin brachte wo sie hingehört nämlich
in das mannigfaltige theorien regal aus
dem man sich auch ungestraft bedienen
kann der anti cheat ehre konsens
allerdings er ist leider aufgeweicht und
das ist ein erfolg jener die die
diktatur nicht diktatur nennen wollen
und es ist eine besondere
langzeitwirkung der kommunistischen
diktatur die mittlerweile weitaus
weniger östlich der oder wirkt als
vielmehr westlich der elbe beispiele
dafür sind die verharmlosung von
linksextremismus heute oder von auf
touristen auch eine revisionistische
geschichtsbild das dem von putin nicht
unähnlich ist und zum beispiel ein
ambivalentes verhältnis zum historischen
fakt des hitler stalin paktes hat findet
man bei manchen die sich heute selbst
des antifaschismus und
dessen freiheit
durch eine mauer
für raub wurde diese idee als
antifaschistischer schutzwall bezeichnet
wurde der kann nicht euphorisch
klatschen sondern der schaut ganz genau
zweimal hin ob diejenigen die gegen
etwas sind auch für das sind worauf es
ankommt nämlich unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung
und insofern dürfen wir uns nichts
vormachen bei geschichte und bedeutungs
kämpfen um die geschichte geht es um die
systemfrage um unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung
ich wünschte die letzten drei wochen
hätten uns nicht in dieser deutlichkeit
zeigen müssen dass und müssen mit ralf
dahrendorf zusagen 1989 nicht ende
sondern wiederbeginn der geschichte war
und zwar im guten wie im schlechten
geschichte verläuft wieder zufällig noch
zwangsläufig sie gibt uns eine
verantwortung
geschichtsvergessenheit ist eine form
des politischen analphabetismus und die
feinde der freiheit ich komme gleich zum
schluss die nutzen geschichte taktisch
die verteidiger der freiheit die
brauchen sie als rüstzeug um unsere
demokratie wehrhaft zu machen und nach
innen und nach außen lassen sie uns
diesen auftrag an den vielen dank
goldberg war das für die fdp fraktion
sind vor dem nächsten redner gehe ich im
alltag der das elektrisierende stimmung
dem antrag der fraktion der cd selig und
das was von ihr ausgehen jetzt hören wir
aber noch ein ergebnis einer
namentlichen abstimmung ging es mal ein
cdu-antrag wenn man mit ja haben
gestimmt
174 mit nein haben gestimmt 466 es gab
eine enthaltung damit ist der antrag
abgelehnt
bekommen sie hat es war der nachtrag es
wurde abgestimmt über einen antrag der
cdu csu fraktion der
mittag gelesen würde allerdings eine
sichere bezahlbare souveräne
energieversorgung und die jüngsten wird
ausgezählt worden der antrag ist
abgelehnt worden euro präsident
jetzt für die linke als nächste
1992 setzte der deutsche bundestag die
enquete kommission
aufarbeitung von geschichte und folgen
der sed-diktatur in deutschland ein
1995 drei jahre später folgte eine
zweite kommission
wir begrüßen es als linke ausdrücklich
dass wir heute an beide kommissionen
erinnern
wir als die linke sind und bleiben in
besonderer verantwortung
richtig und notwendig so bezeichnete
dietmar keller der damalige obmann der
pds diese arquette kommission ja diese
parlamentarischen kommission auch
mehrheitlich ostdeutsch besetzt waren
meilensteine in der aufarbeitung trotz
des parteipolitischen einflusses denn
auch den gab dass insbesondere seien die
bundestagswahl könnte 1994 und 98
erinnert ja und das gehört zum erinnern
dazu die pds sa und die linke sieht wie
auch viele ostdeutsche noch heute
aspekte zur deutsch deutschen geschichte
und zur ddr anders als damals die
mehrheit der an cat die die schwarz
gelbe mehrheit im bundestag ab gebildet
hat aber unzweifelhaft
erstens vor allem und zuallererst die
entschuldigung bei den opfern der
damaligen zeit
zweiter
die feststellung die ddr ist zu recht
gescheitert und drittens die
hauptverantwortung für das was von
diesem system begangen wurde trägt die
sed liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
möchte anders an die damaligen debatten
erinnern zum beispiel zwei aspekte die
wir anders sahen und sehen erster in der
aufarbeitung ging es auch um die frage
der legitimität des versuches nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg ein anderes
deutschland aufzubauen diese legitimität
war da diese legitimität war im ausgang
des zweiten weltkrieges begründet wir
dürfen niemals vergessen auch nicht in
diesen tagen nach dem
völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine ohne die
sowjetunion und die rote armee wäre
europa wäre deutschland vom
hitlerfaschismus nicht befreit wurden
und
auch der zeil und auch deshalb ist
dieser versucht der spätestens nach dem
mauerbau zu recht gescheitert ist nicht
im ansatz zu vergleichen mit dem ns
regime so waren aber die debatten um die
sogenannte zweite deutsche diktatur
das hat sich zum glück verändert im
übrigen hat die gruppe der pds im
deutschen bundestag damals neben der
mitarbeit in der enquete auch eine
eigene schriftenreihe heraus gegeben
immerhin elf bänden der andere
blockparteien könnten sich daran ein
beispiel
zudem gab es auch eine alternative am
kit kommission im osten auch das war
wichtig die pds die einen beträchtlichen
teil der ostdeutschen bevölkerung
vertreten hat hat ihren verdienst bei
der aufarbeitung der einheit und dem
zusammenwachsen unseres landes auch das
sollte heute anerkannt werden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen im schon
benannten entschließungsantrag zum
abschlussbericht der kommission 94 hieß
es damals die politisch moralische
verurteilung der sed diktatur bedeutet
keine verurteilung keine verteilung der
unterworfenen menschen im gegenteil wenn
wir heute an die zeit der aufarbeitung
erinnern müssen wir uns aber auch fragen
über diesem ziel in den vergangenen 32
jahren immer gerecht geworden sind ich
erinnere zum beispiel an den kompletten
personalwechsel nach der wende in den
spitzenjobs der ostdeutschen
gesellschaft oder dass hunderttausende
rentnerinnen und rentner ihre ansprüche
aus ddr-zeiten bis zum heutigen tag
nicht anerkannt bekommen kollegen
möchten sie in ihrer redezeit das ist
jetzt die möglichkeit eine zwischenfrage
zu lassen dann
danke schön danke dass ihr die frage zu
lassen da das wichtig ist möchte ich
kurz nachfragen ob ich sie da richtig
verstanden habe ist das so dass sie
sagen bis zum mauerbau 1961 war es ein
legitimer preis für ihr politisches
anliegen ein bestimmtes ideologisch
anders ausgerichteten staat zu bilden
dass es keine freien und geheimen wahlen
gab in denen die bevölkerung im osten
unseres landes der spd jemals ein mandat
erteilt hätte die geschichte dieses
landes zu bestimmen ist das sozusagen
der legitimen ihrer meinung nach oder
wollen sie behaupten dass es der freie
und geheime wahlen gab frau kollegin
genau da haben sie mich natürlich falsch
verstanden ich habe da nicht gesagt dass
es bis 1961 irgendwie einen
demokratischen versuch eines staates gab
und es ist allgemein bekannt auch das
hat ja der bericht der enquete
kommission mehrfach zu tage getragen
dass es eben undemokratische strukturen
gehabt das war eigentlich demokratisch
stattgefunden haben dass depressionen zu
ertragen war und meine partei der ich
nie angehörte und meine vorgänger partei
hat sich für viele dieser
verfehlungen auch deutlich entschuldigt
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass die das
system der ddr mitgetragen haben auch im
block sich auch entschuldigt hätten das
vermisse ich bis heute allerdings
ich erinnere an den personalwechsel und
an das was die renten betrifft liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen erinnern für
die zukunft so lautet der titel unserer
debatte was könnte das heute heißen die
geschichte der ostdeutschen ist mehr als
sed diktatur das gilt im übrigen auch
für die zeit vor 89 aber was ist mit der
zeit nach 89 die damalige kommission
kann vorbild sein für einen nachwende
enquete-kommission die wir dringend im
bundestag brauchen die fehler der
einheit und der neunziger jahre gewonnen
endlich parlamentarisch aufgearbeitet
die beiden untersuchungsausschüsse zur
treuhand waren keine wahrheitskommission
das konnten sie auch deshalb nicht sein
weil erst heute die akten dazu
zugänglich sind frau präsidentin ich
komme zum schluss ich möchte robert
birnbaum von der bundesstiftung die 1998
als konsequenz wie print wurde noch zum
abschluss zitieren vielleicht hätte man
die herausragende lebensleistung der
ostdeutschen nämlich 40 jahre in einer
diktatur gelebt zu haben und dann einen
gesellschaftlichen umbruchs prozess
sondersgleichen bewältigt zu haben in
den zurückliegenden weil sich an stärker
würdigen müssen vielen dank
der sprecher
der links-fraktion im bundestag
für bündnis 90/die grünen
[Applaus]
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen in diesen tagen ist es kaum
möglich auf unsere in der deutsche
geschichte zurück zu schauen ohne den
blick auch auf den brutalen angriff
streak das menschliche leid in der
ukraine zu richtet die menschen dort
verteidigen irland die demokratischen
werte vor ein diktator und adresse zu
demokratie
frau von storch ihre maske hängt wieder
woanders es fällt auch sehr auf und ich
habe dem gestern schon mehrfach darüber
gesprochen
als nächstes muss ich ihnen dann einen
ordnungsruf erteilt kritische ich habe
heute zeit ja
demokratie wünschen sich aber auch viele
menschen in russland
die zeit angehalten
hermann hat jetzt wieder das wort vielen
dank
demokratie wünschen sich aber auch viele
menschen in russland die sich trotz
drakonischer strafen trauen gegen das
diktatorische putin regime auf die
straße zu gehen sie haben nicht
vergessen was sie und ihre nachbarn
verbindet auch sie wollen frieden und
freiheit der wunsch nach freiheit
demokratie und selbstbestimmung hat auch
89 viele menschen in der ddr gegen die
sed-diktatur auf die straße gebracht
mutig haben sie sich dem autoritären
regime friedlich entgegengestellt
leisteten widerstand in einer diktatur
persönlich hatte ich das glück die
anfangs sehr schwierigen dann aber
ungeheuer befreienden ereignisse
mitzuerleben es war nicht sicher dass es
im herbst 89 friedlich bleibt die
panzerwagen standen hinter unserer
dresdner studentenwohnung keine 300
meter vom stadtzentrum entfernt so manch
einer von uns entgegen um haaresbreite
dem drakonischen zugriff der sich
letztmalig aufbäumenden ddr staatsmacht
wer so etwas vergleicht mit der
situation heute schlägt die menschen von
damals ins gesicht schauen wie ich auf
der weide auf die
zum glück blieb es 89 friedlich um
haaresbreite hätte es anders ausgehen
können nachdem die staatliche einheit
deutschlands wieder hergestellt war trug
der überparteiliche ansatz einer
gemeinschaftlichen aufarbeitung einen
wichtigen beitrag für das
zusammenwachsen unseres landes bei so in
etwa hatte es damals markus meckel
vollkommen zu recht es waren die
erfahrungen bei einer 3er generation
west und ostdeutsche abgeordneter mit
den diktatorischen herrschaftssystem des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts und der block
konfrontation in europa die die themen
und zugleich den langen atem für einen
über sieben jahre während des intensives
aufarbeitungsprozess des deutschen
bundestages prägten als der erste
gesamtdeutsche bundestag 92 die an cat
kommission zur aufarbeitung von
geschichte und folgen der sed-diktatur
in deutschland beschloss da wussten die
akteure das aufarbeitung sehr viel
arbeit und zeit für reflexionen
diskussionen und wissenschaftliche
analyse braucht und dass die anerkennung
von menschenrechtsverletzungen und deren
folgen sowie die entwicklung einer
erinnerungskultur lang während der
prozesse sein werden deswegen war die
einsetzung einer zweiten amt kommission
mitte der neunzigerjahre wichtig die
sich mit der überwindung der folgen der
sed diktatur im prozess der deutschen
einheit auseinandersetzte resultate
waren die gründung der bundesstiftung
zur aufarbeitung der sed-diktatur
1989 88 und 1998 und die entwicklung
einer gemeinsame erinnerungskultur an
beide diktaturen in deutschland
viele opfer der sed-diktatur leiden bis
heute an den folgen des politischen
rechts sind wirtschaftlich und
gesundheitlich schlechter gestellt als
die durchschnittlich all das
entsprechende bevölkerung menschen kamen
zu unrecht ins gefängnis wurden
psychischen druck durch zersetzung
maßnahmen ausgesetzt wurden beruflich
benachteiligt und familien durch
zwangsadoptionen getrennt nicht alle
opfer politischen und rechts sind bis
heute rehabilitiert entschädigt oder
angemessen unterstützt getan ist unrecht
kann nicht wiedergutgemacht werden umso
wichtiger ist dass das im
koalitionsvertrag der erleichterte
zugang zu hilfen und leistungen für die
opfer und die einrichtung eines
härtefallfonds vereinbarten ist heute 30
jahre nach dem einsetzen der ersten an
kommission bewegen mich folgenden drei
gedanken
erstens wir haben eine breite
überparteiliche einigkeit heute wie
damals dass die aufarbeitung der
sed-diktatur unsere gesamtdeutsche
verantwortung ist und bleibt dass sie
teil unserer gemeinsamen geschichte ist
auch das trägt dazu bei unser land
zusammenzuhalten
zweitens wir dürfen die opfer
politischen unrechts niemals vergessen
wir müssen ihrer würdig gedenken und
erinnern neben orten des gedenkens sind
auch bildungsangebote wie zb durch die
bundesstiftung zur aufarbeitung sehr
wichtig es bedeutet aber auch dass wir
diejenigen die noch immer ohne adäquate
anerkennung an den folgen leiden schnell
und stärker unterstützen müssen und
drittens gerade in diesen tagen
wo nach wie vor diktatoren nicht nur die
menschen in ihren eigenen ländern
unterdrücken sondern auch angriffskriege
gegen demokratie führen müssen wir uns
immer wieder vergegenwärtigen wie
wichtig jede und jeder einzelne im kampf
für eine freie und offene demokratische
gesellschaft ist
denn auch das gehört zu den erfahrungen
die ich in zwei grundsätzlich
verschiedene gesellschaftssystemen
machen durfte in der demokratie aber
ganz besonders auch in einem
unrechtsstaat wie der ddr kommt es immer
auch auf das menschliche handeln an auf
die mitmenschlichkeit einer und eines
jeden einzelnen mitmenschlichkeit ist
auch deshalb hoffnung und gebot gerade
für die heutige zeit vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank mir wurde mitgeteilt dass
während der rede von herrn tillmann auf
der fw fraktion einen begriff gefallen
ist der mauer motto hieß und zumindest
und parlamentarisch wäre ich lass das
jetzt im protokoll nachprüfen wie genau
der begriff benutzt worden ist und ob
überhaupt und behalte mir dann
entsprechendes vor
jetzt hat die kollegin gitta connemann
für die cdu csu fraktion das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die opfer nicht aus den augen und aus
den herzen verlieren die war rainer
eppelmann so fassten sie den
leitgedanken der enquete-kommission
aufarbeitung der geschichte und folgen
der sed-diktatur zusammen sie waren
vorsitzender dieser kommission mit ihren
mitgliedern haben sie sich vor 30 jahren
in einer mammut aufgabe gestellt der
aufarbeitung des ddr unrechts staates
und dafür danke ich ihnen auch im namen
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
um diese aufarbeitung geht es heute denn
die geschichte der ddr als sed
unrechtsstaat ist kein abgeschlossenes
historisches kapitel die
teilungsgeschichte wirkt bis heute die
kommission war nicht unstrittig nicht
jeder wollte zurückblicken die einen
hatten genug damit zu tun sich eine neue
existenz aufzubauen
die anderen ligen einen geschönten
ddr-bild an dann gab es die
ideologischen baumeister die großen und
kleinen handlanger der ddr-diktatur sie
wollten nicht erinnern an schießbefehl
zwangsadoption standrechtliche
erschießung am 17 juni an bespitzelung
an entrechtung die stasi war dafür das
instrument aber die täter waren eine
partei nämlich die sed
die sed herrschte verstörend zerstören
zurück blieben ein marodes land mit
kaputter umwelt und industrie eine
gesellschaft die zutiefst traumatisiert
war da gibt es die verleugne bis heute
auch in diesem haus was man mit
geschichtsklitterung machen kann hat uns
der kollege von der linken gerade
eindrucksvoll dargestellt die rote armee
als bejubeln de befreit das ist schon
ein interessantes bild
und dass sie auch heute finden sich
unter den linken immer noch aktivisten
des sed-regimes von der sed über die pds
zu den linken auch das gehört zur
wahrheit dazu und sie sind bis heute
anfällig für diktaturen das zeigt ihr
verzerrter blick auf diktator putin hier
können sie sich übrigens die hand mit
der afg erreichen die den krieg style
darin verheerend und das ist die warnung
für die demokratie nehmt euch in acht
vor den demagogen aller schattierungen
die verflossene diktaturen schönreden
oder erneut den autoritären staat
herbeirufen wollen passt auf genau diese
demokratische kraft führte 1992 zur
einsetzung der kommission
das besondere die aufarbeitung der sed
diktatur wurde nicht als ostdeutsche
aufgabe gesehen sondern als
gesamtdeutsche denn sich mit der ddr zu
beschäftigen heißt immer auch das
geteilte deutschland in den blick zu
nehmen und die mitglieder aus ost und
west aus politik und gesellschaft
arbeiteten über jahre übrigens
ehrenamtlich und mit dem ersten bericht
stand dann ein einzigartiges zeugnis aus
dem heute bereits zitiert worden ist und
der kernsatz der sed staat war eine
diktatur
getragen von einer partei
zu diesem feststellung bekannte sich
1994 die überwältigende mehrheit des
deutschen bundestages übrigens mit einer
ausnahme die pds lehnte dem bericht ab
aber unrecht lässt sich nicht verleugnen
und unrecht hat kein verfallsdatum
viele der empfehlung der beiden
kommissionen wurden in die tat umgesetzt
wie das gedenkstättenkonzept des bundes
dazu gehörten und gehören orte wie die
ehemalige stasi zentrale
hohenschönhausen bautzen und so viele
andere orte an denen menschen gequält
gerecht fechtet und getötet worden mit
der gründung der bundesstiftung
aufarbeitung wurde ein einzigartiges
instrument geschaffen das seit 1998 die
zivilgesellschaft dabei unterstützt die
geschichte weiter aufzuarbeiten und
jüngeren generation zu vermitteln aber
es gibt noch offene punkte die wir
umsetzen müssen gemeinsam mit ihnen der
bundesbeauftragten liebe evelyn zupke
dazu gehören die anerkennung von
verfolgungsbedingten gesundheit
schrieben die bessere psychologische
betreuung der opfer die unterstützung
von opfern wie bei ihrer flucht in
osteuropäischen ländern inhaftiert
worden sind hier sind wir alle gefordert
und übrigens ein denkmal für die opfer
kommunistischer gewaltherrschaft ist
längst überfällig
bei all dem stehen wir an der seite der
koalitionsfraktionen wenn sie gemeinsam
mit uns diese dinge angehen wollten denn
wir dürfen wie rainer eppelmann sagte
die opfer nicht aus den augen und den
herzen verlieren vielen dank
wann war das für die cdu/csu-fraktion
und
ja ein ergebnis
auch der enquete-kommission dass wir
heute immer noch
und wichtiger weise wie hier mehrfach
schon betont wurde die sed opfer
beauftragt und das deutschland des
bundestages
haben über die zunge ist es derzeit ja
auch auf der tribüne platz
[Applaus]
künstlerkollegin und kollegen
liebe kollegin konnte man
ich fand dass die debatte bisher davon
geprägt war die würdigung der arbeit der
enquete-kommission um auch den
vergangenen 30 jahre auch des bundestags
in form auch eine aufarbeitung und
versöhnung darzustellen ich muss sehen
und sagen dass ich die zuspitzung wie
sie jetzt zu beginn der mittelteil ihrer
rede bezogen auf den kollegen peyman
gemacht haben dass ich die nicht nur für
die für falsch gehalten habe sondern
dass sie der debatte auch insgesamt
nicht würdig war auch der ausdrückliche
entschuldigung des kollegen per man
nicht und auch der verantwortung seiner
partei das finde ich gehört an diesem
punkt mit dazu
da komme ich gar nicht auf dem punkt mit
dem blockpartei noch mit denen das wäre
viel zu viel zu billig an diesen punkt
nicht ich will ihnen sagen ich bedanke
mich bei den kolleginnen kollegen merkel
eppelmann thierse und weiteren die heute
alle da sind
die in den 90er jahren
die wichtige aufarbeitung arbeit hier im
deutschen bundestag in der
öffentlichkeit der sed diktatur gemacht
haben die haben dafür die basis gelegt
dass wir gerade in zeiten wo
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse in time
kruden theorien in frage gelegt wird
dass wir eine gemeinsame ausgangsbasis
bewertungsbasis des ddr staates des
sed-unrechts regimes haben war das
extrem wichtig was zu einer befriedigung
auch in der gesellschaft in
ostdeutschland beigetragen hat und frau
kollegin butter hat vorhin
exemplarisch an ihrer familie deutlich
gemacht wie das in den 90ern war bei mir
war das so dass meine mutter
gar keiner partei die wahl nur im fdgb
das ist der gewerkschaftsbund gewesene
mitmach und zum mars platz gekriegt hat
dass sie gleich nach der wende erst mal
wieder gucken musste dass sie als
ingenieurin wo sie ihren job verloren
hatte als selbständiger fischerei wieder
aufgemacht hat es war permanent druck
kann man nennt es ums überleben kämpft
und dazu doch für viele millionen
menschen die teil des systems der ddr
war teil wir hatten selbst
ausreiseantrag gestellt weil ich nicht
ich wollte meine eltern und trotzdem
miteinander zu leben in einem
sportverein zu sein
gemeinsam feste zu feiern das nicht ganz
einfach aber es ist gelungen und das ist
eine große große integrations
aufarbeitung leistung von allen seiten
auch zu verzeihen zu sagen was ist das
offen zu legen auf die stasi-akten alle
verbindungen und dann aber wieder
gemeinsam dieses land diese gesellschaft
zu verbinden und miteinander zu leben
das finde ich ist angesichts der
dimension der
verletzung die viele menschen hat
familien getrennt tote
jugendwerkhöfe
ist das nicht nur nicht zu unterschätzen
eine große soziale leistung unserer
gesellschaft aus und das unter großen
ökonomischen
union ausdrücklich mit ein möchte das
wirklich hier nicht als eine zuspitzung
sehen sondern etwas verbindendes auf
dass wir auch stolz sehen sein können
und der bundestag hat in dieser zeit
mit der mit den beiden enquete
kommission brauche den entscheidungen
für die einrichtung
stasi unterlagenbehörde der stiftung
arbeit aber auch der entschädigungs
gesetze die dann später hast kam aber
hat dafür die richtigen weichen gestellt
um erinnern zu können für die zukunft
und erinnern für die zukunft
ist ein ganz entscheidender punkt weil
nicht nur hier im bundestag diejenigen
die damals
mitten im leben standen in zu ddr zeiten
auch so viele nicht mehr hier sind sind
natürlich noch einige da aber viele sind
mittlerweile keine abgeordnete mehr und
ich finde dass die schlüsse daraus dass
demokratie ständig stets und ständig
verteidigt werden muss und das ist immer
auf den einzelnen ankommt der kollege
von den grünen hat darauf hingewiesen
wir mit wie er damit umgeht wir mit
seiner verantwortung und sein mitgefühl
darum geht dass das uns immer wieder
prägen muss insbesondere auch vor den
herausforderungen die wir haben dass wir
eben nicht in eine totalitäre
gesellschaft kommen sondern eine
demokratische offene bleiben und diese
herausforderung sind nach zwei jahren
kroner nachkriegs angst größer als die
wahrscheinlich in den 2000 und 2010 drei
jahren bank ich möchte im bundestag sie
einladen dass wir die erfahrung die viel
läuft doch viele investoren nach
ostdeutschland gekommen sind dem
wiederaufbau
voran gebracht haben so dass wir heute
ich habe das ein anderer zeitungen
gelesen boomregionen aus deutschland
schreiben können und das nicht als als
schlagzeile die irgendwie sich eine
werbeagentur ausgedacht hat sondern
begründet auf zwei großen
unternehmensentscheidung ansiedlung
sagen nämlich noch bei dem
wirtschaftsministerium bei robert habeck
oder den kollegen und kollegen und trans
ministerium dass die mikroelektronik
ansiedlung in magdeburg mit hinter dass
dies gelegen bedanke mich bei der
landesregierung dort sind über
wahrscheinlich meine 20.000 industrie
arbeitsplätze die geschaffen werden wir
werden die tesla fabrik in den nächsten
wochen ihren brandenburg kann wählen
können das sind klare signale dass der
osten nicht nur gut sondern es ist nicht
nur sehr schön ist und der tapfere
aufrechte kluge menschen wurden sondern
dass hier zukunft ist und ich möchte
diese transformations- erfahrung gerne
mit einbringen in die wir durch extreme
veränderungen viele in ihren biografien
hatten in dieses neu zu gründende von
den koalitionsparteien aber auch der
letzten bundesregierung die union war
dabei zu gründende einheits und
transformations- zentrum das abzubilden
diese erfahrung auch insbesondere als
brückenschlag für die länder in mittel
und osteuropa die ähnliche erfahrungen
gemacht haben die jetzt schon aus
deutschen bezogen nicht denjenigen
hatten noch aus dem deutschen
bundeshaushalt quasi mit unterstützt
wurden in sozialen und ökonomischen
anpassungsprozessen ich glaube dass das
ein brückenschlag auch sein kann um die
und das unverständnis dass zumindest
gegenüber einigen euro
südosteuropäischen ländern in einigen
teilen europas wann ist das zu
überwinden ich möchte sie dazu einladen
dies den nächsten monaten diesem jahr
auch noch mit in die gründungsphase zu
bringen vielen dank
dafür wirbt die kassen schneider hier
das register im kanzleramt ist
beauftragter der bundesregierung für
ostdeutschland seit kurzem in das board
für die alte fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren also nach
dieser rede muss ich ein paar sekunden
meiner begrenzten redezeit glaube ich
dem kollegen schneider widmen dem herrn
staatsminister schneider ich bin schon
überrascht mit welcher
selbstgefälligkeit sie auch die rolle
der spd spd hier beschrieben haben ich
darf doch an einem tag für heute daran
erinnern dass es die spd war die als
erste mit der sed nachfolgepartei mit
den linken ins bett gestiegen ist und
damit auch dazu beigetragen hat dass ein
stück weit die geschichte verharmlost
wurde bei damen und herren man muss sich
natürlich fragen ob bei allem lob was
heute schon zurecht gegenüber den
enquete kommission ausgesprochen worden
ist was tatsächlich davon in der
gesellschaft angekommen ist haben wir
tatsächlich ein bewusstsein dafür was
und wie die ddr wirklich wahr ich
fürchte nein wie sonst ist es denn zu
erklären dass die simple feststellung
dass auch die ddr ein unrechtsstaat war
immer wieder zu politischen kontroversen
führt wie sonst ist es zu erklären dass
der linksextremismus von medien und
politik nach wie vor verharmlost wird
wie sonst ist es zu erklären dass wir 30
jahre über 30 jahre nach dem ende der
ddr diktatur immer noch kein zentrales
denkmal für die opfer des kommunismus
haben das alles meine damen und herren
ist beschämend
das sind allerdings nur die symptome es
ist nicht die krankheit selbst und die
schüler sind nicht dafür verantwortlich
wenn die staatliche wissensvermittlung
versagt die linke indoktrination beginnt
oftmals schon in den schulen wird an den
universitäten vollendet und dass die
mehrheit der journalisten mit
linksradikalen parteien sympathisiert
ist bekannt und das hat auswirkungen
meine damen und herren die die
ehrenwerte arbeit der enquete-kommission
oder auch des forschungsverbundes
sed-staat mitunter ins leere laufen
lassen klaus schroeder der langjährige
leiter des forschungsverbundes sed staat
hat unlängst resignieren festgestellt
ich zitiere die auseinandersetzung mit
dem sed staat hat keinen festen platz in
unserem historischen gedächtnis das
wesen der ddr bestand darin bürger in
untertanen zu verwandeln heute
beschneidet der staat wieder die
freiheit der bürger schränkt die
grundrechte ein ob nun im namen des
klimas neuerdings der gesundheit oder
des demokratiefeindlichen kampfes gegen
rechts wobei meine damen und herren
diese verkürzung kampf gegen rechts ist
natürlich kein zufall mit diesen
fremming grenze sie einen großteil der
demokratischen opposition gleich mit aus
und liebe kollegen von der cdu/csu ich
kann sie nur warnen sich an dieser
stelle vor den karren der linken spannen
zu lassen denn am ende wird er auch sie
über wollen
meine damen und herren der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat unlängst
erklärt in einem podiumsgespräch wir
kämen jetzt in eine phase hinein wo der
ausnahmezustand zur normalität wird herr
lauterbach da werden wir nicht
mitspielen der souverän in diesem land
das ist immer noch der demos das ist das
deutsche volk und demokratie heißt dass
wir die rückverwandlung vom halben
untertanen in ganze bürger wollen das
ist der auftrag für echte demokraten die
lektion aus 40 jahren ddr und das ist
auch die lektion ich komme zum hände aus
der enquete kommission kann nur lauten
nie wieder sozialismus ich danke
[Applaus]
für die fdp fraktion spricht jetzt heute
hier im haus zum ersten mal unser
kollege nico tippelt
dem ich für seine arbeit im haus hier
alles gute wünsche
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrte mitglieder der
enquete-kommission
es ist für mich eine große ehre hier
meine erste rede zu diesem thema in
einem frei gewählten parlament hier im
hohen haus erhalten zu dürfen
ich möchte eine kleine episode aus dem
biografischen gedächtnis meiner familie
voranstellen erlebt inmitten der ddr
wir haben eine familie haben einen
christlichen hintergrund
meine schwester wurde damals im rahmen
ihrer berufsorientierung zu ihrem
schuldirektor vorgeladen
gleichzeitig anwesend euer klassenlehrer
und der sed parteisekretär der schule
die damals noch minderjährige fand sie
statt massiv mit weltanschaulichen
fragen konfrontiert ob ihre oma das
wolle dass sie sich konfirmieren lassen
und sofort mit der verpflichtung dass
sie auf ihre bewerbung mit dem
berufswunsch lehrerin verzichtet
christen sollten keine lehrer werden in
der ddr
meine forderung hat mein vater und meine
mutter sind damals sturm gelaufen gegen
diese verfahrensweise welche
exemplarisch für den umgang des
sed-regimes der ddr mit andersdenkenden
war
und so habe ich eine ganze reihe freunde
denen trotz bester schulischer leistung
verwehrt wurden ist eine weiterführende
schulbildung im sed regime
anzugehen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren schon sind wir mitten in diesem
thema und es stellt sich die zentrale
frage wieso ist es so wichtig
vergangenes unrecht aufzuarbeiten
immer wieder wird unsere demokratie vor
neue herausforderungen gestellt vor über
30 jahren erlebten deutschland und
europa eine welle der euphorie als der
eiserne vorhang fiel ein historiker wie
es schon angeklungen ist stellte gar die
these vom ende der geschichte auf gerade
in diesen wochen erleben wir jedoch dass
die geschichte uns in europa nicht in
ruhe lässt viele von uns in deutschland
und wir haben präsidentiellen ski heute
morgen eindringlich erlebt hätten einen
krieg wie dem russlands in der ukraine
nicht mehr für möglich gehalten
einen satz habe ich in letzter zeit
wieder häufiger gehört man muss nur
lange genug gelebt haben um zu sehen wie
sich geschichte wiederholt die
erkenntnis unterstreicht aus heutiger
sicht warum aufarbeitung und bewältigung
der vergangenheit zu wichtig sind warum
wir uns gerade den weniger schönen
seiten unserer geschichte zu wenden und
stellen müssen
der ancud kommission von 1991 bis 1994
kam erstmals die aufgabe zu sich nicht
nur um die justizielle aufarbeitung zu
bemühen sondern die täter und akteure im
ddr system zu benennen bei dieser
aufarbeitung ging es auch um die
glaubwürdigkeit
unserer gemeinsamen demokratischen
institutionen und darum wie unser staat
und unsere gesellschaft mit vergangenem
unrecht umgehen
die bürger die immer wieder die
aufarbeitung von sed unrecht gefordert
haben haben unsere gesellschaft einen
großen dienst erwiesen sie verdienen
nach wie vor unsere unterstützung die
beiden an ketten kommission haben durch
ihre engagierte arbeit aufgezeigt die
aufarbeitung der sed herrschaft ist ein
gesamtdeutsches thema ein thema welches
uns alle angeht und ich bin dankbar dass
ich dadurch auch familien in ost und
west wieder näher gekommen sind
dankeschön
nico tippelt models für die fdp-fraktion
und seiner ersten rede hier eben
deutschen bundestag erste bei die fdp
landesliste in sachsen und
für das gelb für die
unionsfraktion hören wir jetzt
[Musik]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe vor
ungefähr vier wochen oder nicht ganz
vier wochen gesehen dass der tagespunkt
30 jahre enquete kommission heute
aufgerufen wird und ich habe nicht aktiv
darum bemüht sprechen zu dürfen
und zwar habe ich das aus einem grund
gemacht ich habe am vorabend des
letztjährigen reformationstag das große
privileg gehabt rainer eppelmann in
coburg kennenlernen zu dürfen er hat aus
seinem leben erzählt
er hat aus seiner politischen laufbahn
erzählt und er hat in unglaublich großen
worten die kleinen geschichten der ddr
geschildert
mich hat das heppelmann wahnsinnig
berührt und vor allen dingen haben sie
einen satz gesagt der sich mehr ins
gedächtnis eingebrannt hat
ich würde ihn mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin zitieren als die bürger der
ddr bahn hat václav habe zu ihnen gesagt
hoffnung ist nicht die überzeugung dass
etwas gut ausgeht
sondern die gewissheit dass es sinn
macht egal wie es ausgeht
in meinen augen ist
diese überzeugung
die passendste definition von mut den
man sich überhaupt nur aussuchen kann
es ist eine definition für mut
derjenigen die auf die straße gegangen
sind es ist eine definition für mut
gegen ein unrechtsregime einzustehen es
ist eine definition für mut gegen die
feinde der freiheit hoffnungsvoll
aufzustehen als die enquete kommission
vor 30 jahren eingerichtet wurde waren
die befürchtungen einer parteiischen
aufarbeitung groß ich glaube der 30.000
seitigen abschlussbericht der beiden
kommissionen zeigt dass diese
befürchtungen absolut unbegründet waren
rita süßmuth hat es damals als
einzigartiges zeugnis der vergewisserung
gerade eben erlebte vergangenheit
dargestellt
am eindrucksvollsten
in diesen zeiten sind und bleiben aber
die schilderungen der opfer des regimes
das leid das erlitten wurde
als
in der damaligen debatte zur
entgegennahme des abschlussberichts
der initiator der enquete-kommission
markus meckel ich freue mich sehr dass
sie da sind
resümiert hat es leid kann nicht
rückgängig gemacht werden
verlorenen lebenschancen können nicht
zurückgegeben werden so ist das ein
auftrag für uns alle wenn wir mitnehmen
müssen dass ich geschichte in zukunft
eben nicht wiederholt sepp müller hat
vorhin gesagt er kann sich selber nicht
an die ddr erinnern weil er zu jung ist
ich bin 37
ich kann mich an die ddr noch erinnern
weil mein wahlkreis direkt an der
innerdeutschen grenze liegt und wenn ich
als kind mit meinen papa von coburg nach
kronach gefahren bin dann war da eine
scharfe kurve wo ein großer graeme storm
stand und ich habe damals mit den augen
eines kindes gefragt papa was ist das
und mein vater hat mir gesagt dass es
die grenze dann habe ich gefragt was es
auf der anderen seite dann hat er gesagt
das sind auch deutsche
dann habe ich gefragt waren wir dadurch
hin dann hat er gesagt das ist leider
nicht so einfach
ich habe diese erinnerungen haben sich
bei mir so tief eingebrannt und dann die
kindheit wo du erlebst hier ein volk
zusammen wächst wie die ersten
schulfreunde von ihren fluchtgeschichten
diese früher erlebt haben erzählt haben
wie du auf einmal ein zusammenwachsen
also jetzt wo nicht auf der bayerischen
seite der grenze dass du freunde hat es
die ganz komisch geredet haben
thüringisch und die dann auf einmal
deine besten freude wurden weil du auf
einmal gemerkt hast wir wachsen zusammen
und die jahre wo wir uns selbst als
ossis und wessis definiert haben sie
geraten in vergessenheit
wenn wir heute in diesem haus stehen
dann müssen wir uns bewusst machen was
der deutsche bundestag eigentlich ist
herr printbereich
ihre redezeit war ungewiss und bevor sie
noch weiter vor komisches thüring reden
sag es mal aus zürich
kommen sie doch bitte zum schluss ich
komme zum schluss wir werden uns auch in
zukunft weiterhin und dafür bitte ich
sie um ihre unterstützung vielen dank
dass sie mir zugehört
dass geißler war das für die das waren
natürlich ist also kann es auch so
verstanden
nicht als scherz gemeint ist dass sich
ausweislich des protokolls
die kollegin von storch daran erinnern
möchte dass sie sich der
parlamentarischen wortwahl bitte bemühen
möge sie können alle nachlesen was im
protokoll zu finden ist ich möchte es
nicht wiederholen
als nächstes gebe ich das wort der
kollegin simona koß für die spd fraktion
auch sie hält heute im haus ihre erste
rede und bekommen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen auch wenn wir
schon getan haben lassen sie uns 30
jahre zurück auf das jahr
1992 schauen
damals setzte der zwölfte deutsche
bundestag die and at kommission
aufarbeiten von geschichte und folgen
der sed diktatur ein die arbeit und die
ergebnisse dieser in kat kommission
standen und stehen bis heute im schatten
anderer ereignisse wie etwa den
mauerfall am 9 november
1989 den ersten freien wahlen in der ddr
am 18 märz 1990 oder dem dritten oktober
1990 dem tag der deutschen einheit
dabei meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren hätte es die einsetzung der
kommission durch dieses hohe haus
verdient sehr viel mehr im interesse der
öffentlichkeit zu stehen
ein kurzer blick zurück in das jahr 1992
damals drückten die hohe
arbeitslosigkeit im osten die wohnkosten
der wiedervereinigung die folgen der
stasi bespitzelungen und verfolgungen
und
die ossi wessi diskussionen die stimmung
kurz gesagt es gab genug zu tun mit dem
man sich hätte beschäftigen können aber
es brannte der ehrgeiz und die
notwendigkeit sich mit der geschichte
und den folgen der sed-diktatur
auseinanderzusetzen
mit der einsetzung der kommission war
der hohe anspruch verbunden über 40
jahre ddr nicht nur juristisch sondern
auch moralisch und politisch
aufzuarbeiten
mann widerstand und das war eine große
leistung der versuchung ein tribunal
einzusetzen sondern entschied sich für
ein gremium des deutschen bundestages
als ausweis demokratischer legitimität
die ist meine damen und herren war im
übrigen eine idee von markus meckel dem
sozialdemokratischen mitglied des
deutschen bundestages mit dem ich
gestern telefonieren konnte
die aufarbeitung zur markus meckel
wörtlich war wichtig weil auch ddr
bürgern vieles nicht bekannt war denn es
fehlte öffentlichkeit er hat im gespräch
noch einmal darauf hingewiesen wie
wichtig damals und heute die auseinander
setzen mit der vergangenheit für unsere
demokratische und politische kultur war
und ist
markus meckel war damals ein
oppositionspolitiker und er ist bis
heute stolz darauf dass er aus dieser
rolle heraus die idee einer in kat
kommission einbringen konnte und sich
diese idee durchgesetzt hat
die die nz kommission auf die wir heute
zurückblicken bestand aus 22
abgeordneten und elf experten von den
abgeordneten waren immerhin sieben und
damit fast ein drittel frauen von den
experten nicht
eine heute übrigens undenkbar
beide kommissionen der ersten folgte
bekanntlich eine zweite im 13 deutschen
bundestag haben viel erreicht sie haben
weiße flecken aus mein können wie haben
der geschichtsforschung unglaublich
wichtige unterlagen zur verfügung
stellen können sie haben eine
gesamtdeutsche perspektive einnehmen
können sie haben die bundesstiftung zur
aufarbeitung der sed-diktatur initiiert
und sie haben meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren den menschen die möglichkeit
gegeben sich mit ihrer eigenen
verantwortung und ihrer eigenen
geschichte auseinanderzusetzen
bis heute allerdings wirken die spuren
des sed systems nach bei mir im
wahlkreis in bad freienwalde in märkisch
oderland stand das sogenannte ddr
durchgangsheim im volksmund kinder
gefängnis genannt in dem sogar
dreijährige kinder untergebracht waren
als mutter stock mir der atem
unter unmenschlichen bedingungen wurden
kinder hier bis zu einem halben jahr
festgehalten wie er sie zu
zwangsadoptionen übergeben wurden
erst nach jahrelangem rechtsstreit sind
ehemalige zwangs untergebrachte 2009 10
vom zuständigen landgericht frankfurt
oder
rehabilitiert worden er ist diese
entscheidung hat die tür für weitere
erfolgversprechende
verfahren die haftentschädigung und
opferrente geöffnet
meine damen und herren dieses beispiel
zeigt dass es auch mehr als 30 jahre
nach dem mauerfall noch viel zu tun gibt
jenseits juristischer politischer und
moralischer aufarbeitung wir haben
unseren koalitionstruppen die ganz
konkrete maßnahmen folgen packen wir es
an und verändert das gemeinsam was vor
30 jahren auf den weg gebracht vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
simonis war das ist nur ein mal
der fraktion bei der ersten rede ist die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin
großzügig was die redezeit anbelangt
also simona koß hier ist direkt gewählte
abgeordnete übrigens aus brandenburg im
wahlkreis märkisch oderland barnim
vielen dank frau präsidentin
der ersten enquetekommission zur
aufarbeitung der sed diktatur eingesetzt
vor 30 jahren gehörten 16
bundestagsabgeordnete allen mehrheitlich
aus ostdeutschland den vorsitz übernahm
der ddr bürgerrechtler rainer eppelmann
der fokus dieser enquete lag auf der
analyse der vergangenheit durch
darstellung der zusammenhänge der burg
mechanismen in der sed diktatur zu den
sechs themenfeld und der enquete gehörte
unter 51 rolle und selbstverständnis der
kirche und tatsächlich waren die kirchen
waren christen unter den ersten opfern
der sed
52 wurde entlang der demarkationslinie 1
5 kilometer breiter streifen ein
sperrgebiet eingerichtet somit lage im
katholischen eichsfeld von 85 pfarreien
40 im sperrgebiet
gottesdienste wahl haben prozessionen
waren verboten bischöfen und priestern
die einreise untersagt widerständiges
verhalten wurde mit gefängnis und
zwangsaussiedlungen bestraft in den
akten der abteilung inneres beim
damaligen rat des kreises heiligenstadt
sind diese repressalien
dokumentiert aber es finden sich auch
bericht ihren widerstand welche christen
und kirchgemeinden gegen diese religiöse
unterdrückung geleistet haben sind
glaubenszeugnisse und es gehörte
zivilcourage und mut dazu es war eben
kein spaziergang
der ersten cd umgeht war ein treffen
vorausgegangen von zwei dutzend
politikern mit ddr biografie am 14
dezember 1991
im bonhoeffer haus in berlin eingeladen
dazu hatte der evangelische pfarrer
christian dittrich im ergebnis kam es
zur gründung des forums zur aufklärung
und erneuerung mit wolfgang ullmann als
vorsitzenden unser einsetzung dieser
enquete zur auseinandersetzung mit der
sed-diktatur
der kommissions- auftrag war offene und
verdeckte repressions mechanismen
offenzulegen und das alltagsleben in der
sed diktatur zu erkunden auch sollten
seilschaften und nachwirkungen der
sed-diktatur aufgeklärt werden inklusive
in der motor regierungen denn mit dem
rechtsstaatlichen rückwirkungsverbot war
eine juristische aufarbeitung der sed
diktatur nur eingeschränkt möglich und
die strafverfolgung wurde nach einigen
prozess abbrüchen öffentlich als schwach
wahrgenommen stand zu befürchten dass
die akzeptanz des rechtsstaates
nachhaltig beschädigt wird und
es war den sed funktionären gelungen
sich selbst aus der verantwortung zu
nehmen und alles der staatssicherheit
der stasi in die schuhe zu schieben die
presse und teile auch der westdeutschen
öffentlichkeit machten dabei mit und
ganz ganz schnell saßen sed funktionäre
in den talkshows und erklärten die welt
doch aus den täter von gestern sollten
nicht die gewinner der wende werden und
die menschen aus ostdeutschland sollten
licht aus ihrer geschichte vertrieben
werden am 17 junior sieht ihren 90 hat
dazu gerd poppe im deutschen bundestag
folgendes ausgeführt mit diesem
ungewöhnlichen auftrag hat der deutsche
bundestag neuland betreten es steht ihm
gut an in der ersten legislatur nachdem
zusammen brechen nach dem zustand
gekommen der deutschen einheit diesen
versuch unternommen zu haben
es ging nicht um die demütigung der
ostdeutsche sondern um die
wiederherstellung ihrer würde und weiter
sagt er die ergebnisse sind nicht im
elitären zirkeln sonne in den augen der
öffentlichkeit
zusammengetragen wurden meine damen und
herren diese erste umgeht vor 30 jahren
war der versuch zu einem an die
totalitären konsens zusammen
zusammenzufinden und heute 30 jahre
später diese an die totalitäre konsens
ist uns verloren gegangen auch gibt es
bis heute kein hochschul lehrstuhl zur
geschichte des kommunismus in
deutschland
ob es in die kommen zum schluss ich
finde noch nun der 146 cello professoren
wäre einen lehrstuhl zur erforschung der
sed diktatur nicht weniger bedeutsam
vielen dank im land treffpunkt war das
letzte redner in dieser vereinbarten die
partner mitziehen und
kombis wichtige aufbauarbeit basic die
diktatur es war eine sehr nachdenkliche
debatte in weiten teilen und sind ja auf
der tribüne schon mehrfach angesprochen
worden unter anderem der ehemalige
vorsitzende der cdu abgeordnete rainer
eppelmann der damals vorsitzender der
beiden enquete kommission war von 92 bis
98 auf der anderen tribüne wie seht ihr
auch begrüßt worden beispielsweise
sitzen auch markus meckel
spd damals mitglied ob man neben dieser
ok kommission der auch die initiative
mit ausgegeben hatte auch er bezog
gesehen sie die sed opfer beauftragte
die ausbeute doch gibt es im auftrag des
bundestages der kirche könnte ich
erkenne nicht alle sind unter der maske
rücksicht gar beziehungsweise müssen
auch ein bisschen verteilt und abstatt
hier sieht's aus
die bundespräsidentin die wir an
der kommission auch nochmal
gedankt